in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jerry
and Halina are with us hey guys how are
ya
welcome welcome good to have you say hi
okay you waved and I want to make sure
the radio part was working good okay and
who's this with you
Rosalyn Rosalyn and this is your
daughter yeah and how old is Rosalyn she
just turned 17 awesome very cool and
where you guys live
Columbus Ohio good good to have you guys
thank you for stopping in Nashville we
appreciate it
so you're here to do your debt-free
screen yes sir I love it how much have
you paid off a little over eighty six
thousand dollars good and how long did
that take 32 months 32 months excellent
very good and range of income during
that time I think we started at 1:30 and
we went up down 55 132 155 okay and what
do you guys do for a living
we're both engineers in the automotive
industry okay cool cool good for you
well congratulations very fun what kind
of debt was the 86,000 what do people
buy it was fifty of it was probably cars
fifty was cars of course your automotive
engineer Jeff yeah appreciate a good car
right cool okay what kind of cars were
they are they Toyota 4runner for me yes
her Mercury Sable we get tired of point
transmissions in it so we had to get her
something to drive and then I bought my
first brand new car ever which it was an
F G a cruiser then I soon realized it
wasn't practical so and finding a good
used truck to trade it in on okay it's a
Toyota Tundra yes okay and then we had
maybe 4,500 dollars in student loans
we'd some five thousand dollars in
credit card debt and then we had a
timeshare that was $10,000 and then ATVs
probably ten grain okay so what happened
32 months ago
that made you decide we're getting out
of debt we got engaged we also a little
wedding and we cash flowed our honeymoon
Obon so when did you get married how
long you been married 32 months we we
when we were dating then when we got
engaged we both we both thought that the
other person had less debt than they did
so when did we have the come clean
meeting before marriage I hope I put off
as long as I could and I kind of got
drugged into this kind of kicking and
screaming had my life planned out for me
in an excel sheet for the next two years
and I'm looking at what I get - I get 50
dollars to myself to spend every
paycheck and then the rest of it is all
going to debt and I was like I don't
know if I can do this because two years
just seems like an eternity okay you
delivered that spreadsheet I did I tried
to make it as painless as possible I
tried to tell him if you give me your
paychecks for two years because our goal
is 24 months and I told him I will trade
you two years for the rest of your life
yeah that's a good trade actually very
good trade okay so you but you got you
both ended up getting on board I assume
yes okay and what made you
I only know what made you believe this
start that and start this whole process
we would we would listen to rush on the
radio and you were around the same time
that he was and I couldn't believe some
of the stories and some of the stories
were people just like us mm-hmm and I
thought if they can do it it would be
great a we could do that so I I read
your books and I would listen to you
your podcast and I thought maybe we can
do this maybe maybe we can really do
this that maybe we can do it that hope
is a powerful thing man when that when
that seed gets planted it's hard to keep
it from growing
and then you come in you sit down Jerry
yes maybe we can do this and he's like
$50 you know maybe we could do this
right
well congratulations thank you so what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is because you have paid off
eighty-six thousand dollars in 32 months
that's impressive
I would say it's it's the budget yes
it's yes and there's a lot of stuff that
happened because our goal was 24 months
and then stuff just kept happening you
know like we're pretty unlucky and I
thought I was pretty unlucky but then I
met somebody who's equally one summer or
AC went out like twice and it was I
don't know close to 100 degrees outside
yeah Wow yeah it was like 800 bucks to
figure you know what you kept going and
you got it done
yeah I should say that since we started
doing this everything that we've had to
repair replace like tires lawn mowers
any that kind of stuff we cash flowed
everything we we basically I gave up a
credit card about three years ago and
haven't used one since now yes and we've
bought a lot of nice stuff that we could
have never been able to put on a crack
art yeah like we kept track we kept a
list of everything that we cash flowed
and it's a lot we paid for braces which
are five thousand dollars and we had
doctor bills like $900 in doctor bills I
mean you in normal people just put it on
crackpot
they didn't well they're normal normals
broke you're not normal you're weird the
best kind of weird well congratulations
you guys alright Jerry and Hellena
and Rosalyn from Dublin Ohio $86,000
paid off in 32 months making 130 to 155
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one war dead free
way to go you two very very well done
very proud of you excellent job hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey Channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm Panik so subscribe and there's lots
of videos about life and money so while
you're at it if you want to check out a
video then you can check out how to do a
monthly budget it's one of the best
videos out there
you